êtes journaliste et agent d'artistes et
vous dites que le racisme anti asiatique
est un racisme ordinaire
discret et sournois dit c'est un mélange
de préjugés et d'amalgamés on vous
appelle parfois il paraît le chine toc
on m'a perd on m'appelait le tx2 shinto
maintenant eh ben non on m'appelle le
combat le coronavirus nom alors je vois
des gens qui est en fait on assimile le
on assimile le chinois et d'asiatiques
donc il ya déjà un premier amalgame un
deuxième podium c'est le chinois avec le
coronavirus et donc du coup tous les
étés qui sont censés porter le
coronavirus voilà donc c'est plus que la
triste expérience que j'ai eus lundi
il ya quinze jours et ce qui s'est passé
j'étais dans le métro ouais t'es assis à
côté de moi me suis tassé s'était pas
monsieur
mais attention attention j'aime assez ce
bien sûr mais voilà donc le monsieur qui
était assis à côté de moi c'est décalé
de quelques centimètres
et il a mis son écharpe devant sa bouche
pourtant je ne poussais pas le voisin en
face tous et par contre mais c'était pas
pour moi c'était enfin le les sharks
étaient pour moi pour le musée parce
qu'ils pussent et quelques minutes
précédemment
nous voilà donc moi ça m'a choqué
honnêtement je crois vous en souffrez
gensou pas parce que je fais chier voilà
je suis chemin vers sont donc sur vous
la france est raciste
la force n'est pas raciste mais il ya
des racistes en france mais en fait ce
qui est ce qui me fait souffrir c'est
c'est pas mon cas c'est des cas de
dizaines de d'asiatiques qui vivent
depuis l'apparition du virus
il ya quinze jours ce sont des femmes
qui sont jetés du bus qui sont cracher
dessus
c'est des enfants qui sont bannis des
écoles voilà bon ya pas mal de choses
qui se passent et le racisme
c'est en fait c'est vrai c'est la boîte
de pandore qui c'est qui s'est ouverte
alors joly on nous sommes allés dans le
métro muni d'une caméra cachée avec
notre intervenant sur les cannes c'est
vous qui avez fait d'ailleurs la caméra
cachée merci merci à vous terrasse oui
voilà
regardez les réactions des gens autour
regarder
[Musique]
présents
loire
[Applaudissements]
bon alors là c'est un peu caricatural
voilà voilà ce qu elle sur caméra cachée
oui surtout que vous tous et on est en
période un peu de psycho the trigger
suis pas sûr que ce soit contre vous
vous aurez en regard d'une part et
d'autre chose à aubervilliers on pense
que les chinois ont de l'argent donc ils
sont agressés certains sont tués et là
on peut vraiment parler de racisme alors
à enrichir de caméras cachées dans le
métro on peut peut-être être un peu plus
je peux dire jeu sympa mais un peu plus
compréhensif vis-à-vis des utilisateurs
même s'installer dans la rue demander
aux gens comment ils voyaient la
communauté asiatique en france
vous allez voir le résultat est assez
édifiant regarde bas en ce moment
racisme petite taille ce truc est une
nouvelle antenne taille
arts martiaux nouriture à l'inria
l'écriture chinoise tout sourire le dise
où j'y suis je veux dire nombreux
c'est la thématique algérie sans novus
je trouve que c'est un peuple très
gentil très très accueillants très
simple voilà que j'aime que j'aime bien
quoi la voilà alors c'est vrai voilà
c'est le coronavirus ça revient
forcément ce moment les séries k
peinture doit qui font les vannes en ce
moment alors pour nous ça peut être des
vannes
mais pour vous c'est vrai que ça ça
devient c'est à dire en béton au jour le
jour ça devient très embêtant parce
qu'en fait ce racisme ac c'est un
racisme ordinaire
mais est ce qui se cache en fait un
racisme enfin le race était latent fait
ça prouve que le racisme et l attend on
revient pas à ce que vous me disait tu
me disais j'ai me mohamed s'était en
fait aubervilliers aubervilliers en fait
c'est le symbole du rêve aubervilliers
ses idées agressé dans le 93
voilà donc en ile de france et il ya une
forte communauté chinoise est en fait
c'est à dire le savoir c'est qu'il ya un
azerty qui se fait agresser tous les
deux jours il repart et la petite
couronne un asiatique qui se fait
agresser tous les deux jours ces
attaques sont principalement des femmes
d'accord 80% des personnes qui se font
agresser sont des femmes voilà donc
et là on voit bien que c'est du racisme